[Music]
last week is kind of an unbelievable
story but it's true last week the porn
site pornhub and I'm when there's a porn
story I'm all over it
the the porn site pornhub announced it
would start featuring adult videos with
narration for the blind and visually
impaired yeah that's right hurting me so
basically the idea is while the clip
while the porn clip is playing a
narrator will be describing the
pornographic action now I have to say
this is a big improvement from the
current way that blind people experience
porn check it out oh boy hey come on
Toby what's going on
[Music]
now you shouldn't applaud that little
sketch and you shouldn't I'm because I
have problems with what just happened I
have problems with that clip we just
showed let's go over them
shall we right now first of all if this
blind man is in his own home why is he
holding his walking cane he's not on the
street makes no sense plus he's holding
the cane upside down that's exhibit a
about why this is bad second why is
there a hang gliding poster on his wall
maybe he enjoys tandem gliding with an
instructor bream if he did why would a
blind man have a poster of it up on his
wall third notice that the computer has
a mouse a mouse moves a cursor on a
screen why would a blind man have a
mouse on his computer which brings me to
my final issue right here we're supposed
to believe that service dogs can log on
to porn sites click on videos and then
describe the action in the videos by
barking and somehow blind people can
translate barking into English I'm sorry
that is a lot to swallow its basic who
said that
I don't I don't hate blind people I just
don't think you can understand what dogs
are barking no nobody can I'm not
getting into this right now we'll talk
after the show
no I was gonna say that I didn't say it
cuz you interrupted me with very few
barks he does a lot oh oh there you go
oh okay good okay - okay he's he's never
doing it now
you